has it been a lot I mean yeah I mean
loads of firsts like all at once it's
just like trying to process it all and
be pressing for it oil and I'm enjoying
it because I get to do the thing I love
the most and I get to do it a lot now
which is like what does it also mean to
be the only woman of color nominated an
acting category this year
bittersweet and I and I really want
people to see it and think you know this
it doesn't look right there's a feel
right I want us to be celebrated I want
us to because we work hard all year long
and good work out and these beautiful
pictures that means we makin this
beautiful stories that we tell and those
deserves celebration as well so we
should be able to be there to Harriet
Tubman Aretha Franklin these iconic
woman women what does it mean to play
women of such stature that means so much
to us well the thing more than the fact
with their iconic their stories are
unheard their stories are complex
the stories are full their hearts beat
with right within the middle of it and
that's the thing that I'm really honored
to be able to do bring these
and give it for people again tell their
stories ago our people ready for your
Aretha because I know I mean I don't I
don't think the majority there are some
people out there that don't know have
not heard you sing and I don't know that
they're ready for your you know well I
don't know if they're ready I mean I
don't I hope that they're not ready but
willing to see what I can bring yeah
what is your what is your Aretha moment
what is the song that you got to sing
that was your mother was there one the
first time I sang live it was never
loved a man the way I loved you and I
had to I did that live and so I don't
know if something just shifted it felt
good and but I'm sure there's gonna be
moments where like in the middle of
filming it's still like I'm still yeah
yeah I'm still working and by the way
people have no idea about
Aretha 's life was so crazy and up and
down in the pen she had a lot going on
she the emotional trials and
tribulations that she had to go through
is unbelievable and hopefully we get to
crack into some of that and share it
with you and let you see that this was a
woman who was successful beyond the
means that she had let me let you go but
lasting have you picked a dress I have
picked a dress
you're set I'm very sick I fit today
today I thought yeah I did my first
fitting for it today
I can't wait
[Music]